d'ici au 31 décembre la notion de ville
comme on la connaît ne va plus exister
les communes doivent se regrouper à
l'instar de ce qui existe depuis 40 ans
dans l'agglomération cinquantinoise cela
a fait l'objet d'apre discussion entre
les élus et la commission départementale
de coopération intercommunale a arrêté
son périmètre en ce qui concerne la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans
niveline pas dévolution du périmètre pas
de commune entrante ni de villes
sortante la casquille reste au nombre de
morpa et coignère feront une
intercommunalité à deux un moment morpa
avait souhaité intégrer l'agglomération
cinquantinoise notamment par la voix de
son premier adjoint Pierre Le guuérinel
etcoanière avait évoqué un rapprochement
de son côté vers la communauté
d'agglomération de la Haute Vallée de
Chevreuse mais finalement il n'en serura
rien plaisir les clés sous-bois et
Villepreux se regroupent un trio qui
devra trouver son harmonie car la
solution avait été rejetée en son temps
par l'ancien maire P de plaisir Joë rot
estimant qu'il s'agissait d'une erreur
et du côté des clés sous-bois on avait
clairement affiché sa préférence pour
Versailles Grand Parc voire pour C an
ivelin mais rien n'est définitivement
acté la loi du 29 février 2011 permet de
faire évoluer ses périmètres avec une
clause dite de revoyure en 2015 ce sera
donc un des enjeux des prochaines
élections municipales de mars